ok also ich habe ja schon hallo gesagt 1
2 3 4 5 6 11 haben wir jemanden verloren
[Musik]
denkt daran dass der name den wir mit
uns herumtragen nicht nur dazu dient das
andere sagen wie gut wir auf dem platz
sind sondern auch wie gut wir außerhalb
des platzes sind so macht man einen
unterschied ok kinder
wohin geht ihr nach wien wie und was
werdet ihr dort machen ein turnier ein
fußballturnier mit starken teams ja
bayern münchen ziemlich gut und stark
lokomotive moskau salzburg wie alt seid
ihr
[Musik]
erster juni flughafen malpensa ein team
von acht bis neunjährigen macht sich auf
die reise gefolgt von einer entourage
die der champions league würdig ist
setzt euch alle hin und steht erst auf
wenn ich eure namen aufrufe
so etwas hatte es in lugano noch nie
gegeben ständig spielen jungfußballer
aus aller welt internationale turniere
wenn man alle altersgruppen
berücksichtigt ist dass der dreißigste
flug und das 70 c turnier im ausland
das ist so ähnlich wie unser motto wie
wir den fußball verstehen bei diesem
lied musste ich sofort an euch denken
ich weiß
[Musik]
ein hoch auf die freiheit ein hoch auf
die freiheit
[Musik]
ja immer näher mit der klage
überhaupt denn timo koschollek
windenergie
die wahre liebe
russische revolution im cornaredo
b
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die party
bist du müde
ja
ich habe großen hunger ich auch es ist
fast mitternacht als wir mit den jungen
fußballern aus lugano in wien ankommen
um den nachmittag in der schule nicht zu
verpassen haben sie einen flug am späten
abend genommen doch hunger und müdigkeit
können ihnen die lust auf das abenteuer
nicht verderben dass sie gerade erleben
einen traum abenteuer sie werden gegen
weltberühmte teams antreten und eine
neue großstadt entdecken
[Musik]
glaubt ihr die kuppel ist rund nein nein
was ist sie dann
sie ist oval und war um 1700 eine
sensationelle konstruktion
[Musik]
also hat dieser typ ein eigenes
schokoladen gericht erfunden man nennt
ist heute sachertorte
[Musik]
lätta spot oder dritte reise dauert drei
tage und das programm beinhaltet auch
eine führung durch die stadt alle kosten
werden übernommen sogar die
reiseleiterin die den kindern die
schönheit wiens auf 1700 näher bringt
aber wer bezahlt das alles
[Musik]
[Applaus]
prima spa regierung wie viele spieler
haben wir in der ersten mannschaft von
lugano wie viele in der champions league
und diese kontinuität ist nicht gut für
uns bedeutet kontinuität eine
kontinuität der exzellenz so denken wir
können sie uns sagen wie viel geld sie
in die jugendabteilung der mannschaft
von lugano investieren mehr oder weniger
eine million pro jahr
in logan gibt es einen russischen herrn
der viel geld investiert um hier die
wichtigste fußballschule der welt zu
gründen sein name ist leonie knüwer
sales kam um sein ziel zu erreichen
hatte etwa 70 leute eingestellt von
mitarbeitern bis hin zu trainern die er
größtenteils vom ac mailand und anderen
großen italienischen vereinen abgeworben
hat und jetzt will er das ganze team mit
einbeziehen
das tessin ist meiner meinung nach ein
perfekter ort für fußball es gibt viele
plätze das wetter ist schön es gibt
viele kinder wirklich viele wir müssen
nur diejenigen ansprechen die noch nicht
fußball spielen
ich werde oft gefragt ob unsere
hauptkonkurrenten hockey oder basketball
sind aber nein unser konkurrent heute
ist das ipad
oder die playstation
ja heutzutage treiben die kinder keinen
sport mehr
wenn wir sie von klein auf ansprechen
und sie mit einem guten projekt und
einem traum dazu motivieren können die
höchsten ligen zu erreichen werden wir
auf die zahlen kommen
break
[Musik]
da
unglaubliche gefunden
[Musik]
projekt lugano ist ein ehrgeiziges
projekt das auf den willen unseres
präsidenten leonid nowizki zurückgeht er
hat uns trainern und dem gesamten
personal angefangen bei den
organisatorischen aspekten die chance
gegeben einen traum zu leben und alles
gemeinsam aufzubauen während wir spieler
von internationaler klasse ausbilden
teodoro palaterra kommt ebenfalls vom ac
mailand seit jahren kümmert er sich um
jugend akademien in der ganzen welt in
lugano ist er nun der trainer der
gesamten jugendabteilung
[Musik]
sehr gut
ok welche seite des fußes benutzen wir
für die känguru übung vorne oder hinten
job des fcc beispiele und übungen zur
förderung der motorik und koordination
eigenschaften die immer wichtiger werden
und vielen kindern fehlen daraus besteht
der unterricht am mittwoch für kinder im
alter von vier oder fünf jahren und
darüber also im richtigen alter um gute
fußballspieler zu werden schon 650 junge
menschen zwischen sechs und 15 jahren
sind teil dieses projekts zwischen
fußballschule und wettbewerbsaktivitäten
für kinder etwa 50 von ihnen kommen aus
italien aber wie ist es dazu gekommen
ich habe hier an der resale ski zu hause
getroffen um ihn besser kennen zu lernen
ich wohne nicht in lugano ich sage immer
ich lebe im flugzeug jede woche fliege
ich zur arbeit nach russland dann komme
ich für ein wochenende oder ein langes
wochenende hierher zurück
[Musik]
deutlich
zwölf jahren ja vor zwölf jahren haben
uns unsere freunde empfohlen hierher zu
kommen als meine frau schwanger war
sie sagten santana sei eine großartige
klinik ein großartiger ort um das baby
zu entbinden
wir haben uns sofort in lugano verliebt
in das tessin das unserer meinung nach
der beste ort auf der welt ist in dem
man leben kann vor allem wenn man kleine
kinder großzieht
inzwischen haben sie drei kinder die
alle in der klinik santana geboren
wurden und während er immer wieder aus
russland zurück kehrt lebt seine frau
dauerhaft in paradiso
[Musik]
eines der weltweit größten unternehmen
für diese art von verbraucherprodukten
ein unternehmen mit 6000 mitarbeitern
und das nur in russland
ja nur in russland
wir arbeiten in der ganzen welt wir
produzieren in verschiedenen ländern
aber wir verkaufen nach russland oder in
die östlichen länder ukraine
weißrussland kasachstan mit unserem
management führen wir strategie
sitzungen durch
und wir machen immer irgendwelche
extremsportarten wie klettern oder
rafting und am abend sprechen wir dann
über strategisches
herr nowitzki ist ein typischer
unternehmer der nach dem zusammenbruch
der sowjetunion sein vermögen gemacht
hat in den 1990 er jahren zusammen mit
drei partnern gründete ein unternehmen
für kosmetika und haushaltsprodukte mit
dem namen great event das sich zur
nummer eins in diesem bereich entwickelt
hat und heute unter den 200 größten
russischen unternehmen gelistet ist
fußball ist meine lebenslange
leidenschaft seit ich auf der welt bin
ich wurde in kiew geboren von klein auf
habe ich mit freunden fußball gespielt
ich hatte trikots berühmter spieler dann
sind wir noch moskau gezogen und haben
bis zum alter von 14 jahren für dynamo
moskau gespielt
als max mit dem fußballspielen begann
wurde er in die mannschaft von lugano
aufgenommen ich sah wie sie trainierten
und dachte ich könnte das niveau
verbessern
ich wollte helfen sich unterbreitete dem
verein einen vorschlag für ein
pilotprojekt mit einem ansatz der etwas
ehrgeiziger und professioneller war
der nächste schritt bestand darin angelo
renze titeln präsidentin des vereins von
lugano zu bitten ihnen die gesamte
jugendabteilung anzuvertrauen er zahlte
eine million pro jahr die hälfte des
budgets als gegenleistung für die
garantie dass er allein entscheiden
würde so begann das neue projekt
[Musik]
wir wollen dass alle mitmachen wir
können nicht alles alleine machen und
die arbeit im team wird die jungen
menschen begeistern
michelle breuning sechs professoren der
universität rennings war professor an
der universität von löwen in belgien wo
er vor etwa 15 jahren auf basis
verschiedener gehirn forschungen eine
kognitive trainingsmethode namens koki
training entwickelt hat die er in die
ganze welt exportiert michelle ist einer
von mehreren weltbekannten spezialisten
die leonid nowizki nach cornaredo geholt
hat
komm her
sprechen wir englisch oder französisch
ich habe festgestellt dass viele kinder
ihrer füße nicht richtig benutzen wenn
sie trainieren
wir lassen sie zuerst auf dieser weißen
linie vorwärts laufen ja und beobachten
sie dann genau während sie rückwärts
laufen wenn sie ihre füße nicht sauber
auf der linie ab setzen bedeutet das
dass ihr gleichgewichtssinn und ihre
körperkontrolle noch nicht voll
entwickelt sind
gib mir zehn leute für den spot
also 1 bald für jeden
die müsst ihn anpassen
ball auf dem boden
schnurgerade und an die hüfte
halte ihn so
weißt du wie man das nennt
sehr gut weiß du wieder heißt sense ball
sehr gut
[Musik]
nur nicht nur bewegen sondern auch
zählen
[Applaus]
als michelle bemerkte wie erstaunt ich
waren lud er mich zu einem test ein und
erklärte mir was es mit dieser seltsamen
kugel an der schnur auf sich hat
ich denke lediglich der hand den ball
hin und her zu schwingen ich habe dir
das andere du willst ich bewege meine
hände nicht
das ist ja wie bei uri geller
du kannst es auch versuchen es ist
nichts außergewöhnliches wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass unser körper ja
voller energie ist konzentriere dich auf
die bewegung ich stelle mir vor dass er
sich von links nach rechts bewegt
jetzt wechseln
und her ich muss versuchen den ballen
mit der kraft der gedanken zu bewegen
der wirtschaft die mobile und laut
michelle kann allein der gedanke der vom
gehirn aus geht einen gegenstand bewegen
ganz ohne die muskeln einzusetzen
eingesehen center wind oder muskel
unglaublich
[Musik]
dass der zweck eines tänzers dient dazu
der erklärt dass alles was wir im gehirn
tun von einem rhythmus bestimmt wird
das heißt wenn wir die ganze energie auf
den ball konzentrieren wirkt das
metronom prinzip
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieser an einer schnur befestigt der
ball ist der hauptgegenstand des kobe
trainings er ist das geheimnis des
großen qualitätssprung im belgischen
fußball und wurde erfolgreich von den
jugendmannschaften des ac mailand und
vielen anderen großen europäischen
vereinen übernommen ich beschloss
michelle nach belgien zu folgen um mehr
zu erfahren
[Musik]
auch eine delegation aus den emiraten
ist da
ja es ist eine erstaunliche erfahrung
für mich
als ich michael vor dem stadion von
crank traf wo er einst mit dieser neuen
trainingsmethode begann erzählte er mir
dass auch eine delegation aus den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten zu uns
kommen würde die delegation wurde von
diesem programm magisch angezogen
nachdem einige der jugendlichen aus renk
es in nationale und ausländische vereine
gebracht hatten
die ergebnisse können spektakulär sein
du wirst es sehen
alles ist rhythmus
sie zählen auf verschiedenen sprachen
niederländisch
französisch so bleibt das gehirn
beschäftigt
warum lässt man sie zählen
weil dadurch ein bestimmter teil des
gehirns blockiert wird den via
präfrontalen kortex nennen
alle technischen bewegungen müssen
automatisiert werden man kann sie nicht
bewusst einsetzen
wenn der brief frontalen kortex aktiv
ist dringen andere gedanken in das
gehirn ein wir werden abgelenkt und
schon ist es vorbei
die man bei dieser übung sehen kann sind
sie verpflichtet sich an die
synchronisation zu halten sie werden ihr
etwas alleine tun können im fußball muss
man im blick haben wo die mitspieler
sind der gegner der ball wo man sich
selbst auf dem spielfeld befindet die
spieler müssen viele dinge gleichzeitig
tun
das cookie training besteht nicht nur
aus dem einsatz des senders sondern auch
aus einer reihe anderer übungen bei
denen jede körperliche bewegung mit dem
denken verbunden ist laut michelle
brünings hilft die sauerstoffversorgung
des gehirns bei der verarbeitung von
konzepten und mustern
[Musik]
bei lernprozessen sind sprache und zeit
von großer bedeutung nichts im leben
geschieht ohne den einfluss der zeit
darauf
des rhythmus genau wie in der musik
unser gehirn ist so aufgebaut wenn du
der inneren uhr deines gehirns nicht
folgst wirst du probleme bekommen
ein problem
zum beispiel sind kinder mit
aufmerksamkeitsstörungen oder
hyperaktivität nicht in der lage die
funktion ihres gehirns zu steuern
die funktion des gehirns wird durch die
zeit geregelt
wenn ich es richtig verstehe ihr
perfektionieren diese übungen nicht nur
die fußball technik sondern auch die
konzentration und das
erinnerungsvermögen
deshalb ist der einsatz von koki
training nicht nur auf den fußballplatz
beschränkt
michelle wollte dass ich eine
grundschule am rande von lüttich in
flims besucher wo diese methode im
rahmen eines traditionellen schul
lehrplans erprobt wird
[Musik]
im französischunterricht lernt man mit
kogge training zum beispiel die endungen
des imperfekt
gestern wir spielen
[Musik]
fertig die
1.222 wenn es um matte geht hilft der
sense ball beim auswendiglernen von
formeln und das einmaleins
wenn es nur vier fünf oder zehn kindern
hilft ihre leistungen zu verbessern dann
ist das schon ein erfolg
wir haben zwei tage lang mit michelle
breunings trainiert und seit januar
setzen wir diese methode der gehirn
verbindung auch im unterricht ein
[Musik]
was den ursprung des namens von lugano
betrifft gibt es mehrere theorien vom
götter name des keltischen luke
beschützer der gewässer aus dem
lateinischen mittelalterlichen lag
wahllos bewohner am see
es hat mir sehr geholfen mich im
training zu konzentrieren also habe ich
versucht das selbe mit meinen
hausaufgaben zu tun ich habe
festgestellt dass es funktioniert also
habe ich weitergemacht und es läuft sehr
gut
weist ein lehrer dass du zu hause
übungen mit dem essence ball machst
ich glaube nicht dass er es weiß aber er
weiß dass sich sozusagen eine geheime
methode habe habe ich habe es ihm noch
nicht gesagt
elia maslar ist elf jahre alt und geht
in die fünfte klasse in sulden seit
eineinhalb jahren fährt er fast jeden
tag zwischen lugano und cornaredo hin
und her um zu trainieren
ich wache morgens auf und gehe zur
schule
dann am nachmittag sobald es an der tür
klingelt renne ich nach unten wenn es
ein trainingstag ist wie ich steige ins
auto und fahre nach lugano und ziehe
mich im auto um wenn wir ankommen steige
ich aus und gehe zum training
[Musik]
ich komme abends zurück so gegen 20 uhr
15 20 uhr 20 ich esse direkt zu abend
und bevor ich ins bett gehe habe ich
noch eine halbe stunde 20 minuten zeit
wenn ich noch etwas für die schule zu
tun habe vielleicht ein paar unerledigte
hausaufgaben mache ich die ansonsten
lege ich mich auf die couch
schlafen und mein tag ist zu ende das
ist sehr anstrengend am anfang war das
sehr viel aber jetzt habe ich mich daran
gewöhnt und
wie sind deine noten in der schule
meine noten sind sehr gut ich habe
überall dies außer dreimal de - ich bin
sehr glücklich mit meinem leben denn
mein traum als kleines kind war es ein
tor gegen barcelona zu schießen ich
hatte das glück dort zu spielen und
konnte meinen traum verwirklichen
der erste halt ist die nero brawn
abzuholen der zwölf jahre alt ist und in
minusio die sechste klasse besucht beide
kinder haben auf wunsch von leonore
celski das team von lugano verlassen um
in lugano zu spielen
[Musik]
ich habe mit elia in der mannschaft von
lugano gespielt und im januar sind wir
zu lugano gewechselt die ausbildung ist
hier spezifischer anders als in locarno
in lugano trainieren wir viermal pro
woche eineinhalb bis zwei stunden lang
und das sehr intensiv auf diese weise
verbessern wir uns jedes mal
dann spielt ihr samstags und sonntags
noch es sind immer entweder
freundschaftsspiele oder internationale
turniere was ist ein traum
zunächst einmal dass lugano trikot der
ersten liga zu tragen und internationale
spiele auf sehr hohem niveau zu
bestreiten oder vielleicht eines tages
in der nationalmannschaft zu spielen
[Musik]
wenn der faden nicht gespannt ist
bedeutet das dass du nicht konzentriert
bist bereit und los
[Applaus]
die markierung von zeit und raum die
synchronisation die sie haben ist von
größter bedeutung für ihre konzentration
das ist ein instrument das wir vor allem
im training und vor dem spiel einsetzen
weil wir festgestellt haben dass es die
kinder in vorbereitung auf das spiel
dazu bringt ein sehr hohes
konzentrations und wickeln
[Musik]
überraschung nach einer zinssitzung
sprechen wir heute im cornaredo spanisch
die trainer des fc barcelona kommen auf
das spielfeld im modernen fußball gelten
sie als die besten trainer der welt
[Musik]
wir wollen mit den besten der welt
arbeiten und wenn man die möglichkeit
hat mit den besten der welt zu arbeiten
kann man auch wenn nicht das beste
zumindest ein sehr hohes niveau
erreichen
die neuerung nehmen kein ende nach der
belgischen methode von michelle
breunings und der vorreiterrolle des
spanischen fußballs kam ein echter
fußball guru nach lugano tom beyer ein
ehemaliger amerikanischer fußballspieler
der auch in asien sehr bekannt ist
nachdem er den fußball in japan populär
gemacht hat versucht er nun das niveau
des chinesischen fußballs anzuheben
so tomba ist berühmt für seinen ansatz
in der arbeit mit sehr kleinen kindern
wenn ich sehr klein sage meine ich die
neugeborenen appell an athen
arbeite in china wohl es 100 millionen
kinder unter sechs jahren gibt so in
china haben sie die besten trainer der
welt angeheuert lippi capello sven
eriksson sie haben sie eingestellt
gefeuert und wieder eingestellt aber bis
jetzt hatten sie den falschen ansatz
weil sie die arbeit mit jüngeren kindern
und ihren familien vernachlässigt hatten
sie sind es auf die man sich
konzentrieren sollte wenn man die besten
spieler haben und die fußball welt
verändern will
jetzt zeige ich ihnen meinen
zweijährigen sohn er hat einen kleinen
ball einen kleinen fuß und er ist in
einer engen umgebung und ich ermutige
ihn den ball hin und her zu spielen
rechter fuß linker fuß wie ein spielzeug
er spielt in seiner umgebung ich halte
ihn nur davon ab zu kicken ja sollte
nicht kicken
warum sollte er nicht kicken
ok ich werde ihnen zeigen warum das ist
ein park ein öffentlicher platz wenn ich
ihn kicken laster wird er bald lernen
den ball weg zu geben anstatt ihn zu
beschützen und zwischen den füßen zu
halten war es mehr spaß macht er ist
klein und seine beine sind kurz er kann
auf engem raum bleiben wenn ich ihn zum
kicken auffordere renter dem ball
hinterher und wird nicht besser
dann er sofort müde und wird auf
[Musik]
die zeitspanne vom ersten bis fünften
lebensjahr ist wichtig bevor man in
einen professionellen club eintritt wie
kann man das erreichen
kann nur durch die einbeziehung und
erziehung der familien fußball zu hause
das ist die idee fußball zu hause
wir müssen den richtigen weg finden um
die familien einzubinden ich weiß noch
nicht wie wir das anstellen werden wir
werden nach wegen suchen um es zu
erklären sie zu überzeugen familien zu
unterstützen die den traum haben dass
ihre kinder fußballer werden
und wer im alter von einem jahr anfängt
hat mehr möglichkeiten als andere
[Musik]
als präsentator bei der ersten schulung
stellte sich leonid nowizki vor und
erklärte das ganze projekt
und wir fanden es toll
als er sagte ich will gegen juventus
gewinnen gegen chelsea er sagte ich will
spielen nein er hat gesagt ich will
gewinnen
sowohl judith luig will dass lugano
gegen chelsea gegen juventus und
manchester city gewinnt
ich dachte dieser mann ist verrückt
können unsere kinder gegen chelsea
gewinnen aber es ist fünf oder sechs
monate her sie haben mit ihren trainern
gearbeitet alle zusammen als team wir
haben gegen chelsea 2 1 gewonnen wir
haben gegen juventus zwei zu null
gewonnen dieses jahr haben wir auch
gegen liverpool gewonnen und wir haben
unentschieden gespielt sie haben zwei
oder dreimal gewonnen ja gegen große
mannschaften wie mailand genua werder
bremen turin das waren alle
[Applaus]
sie motten hat ja wie ende doch wir sind
zurück in wien wo es jetzt ernst wird
die kleinen touristen die wir im
stadtzentrum vor dem stephansdom
zurückgelassen haben werden heute bei
einem turnier auf hohem internationalen
niveau antreten
etwas nach links tommy etwas nach rechts
simon
das schöne an diesen turnieren und an
diesem turnier einen besonderen es ist
nicht jedem gegeben so etwas zu erleben
also genießt dieses turnier spielt mit
einem lächeln und spielt mit dem
richtigen biss wenn wir fehler machen
bedeutet das immerhin dass wir es
versucht haben
die kinder ja auf geht's
andrea beer gilt in italien als der
beste trainer für die ausbildung 8 und 9
jähriger spieler nachdem er erfolgreich
für atalanta gearbeitet hatte wechselte
er zum ac mailand bevor sich lugano
anschloss
wie schön
mein sohn hat bei stella capri öfter
gespielt und dann wollte er nach lugano
gehen er hat an der fußballschule
cornaredo angefangen und sein trainer
wollte ihn in seiner mannschaft haben er
ist der einzige in 2010 geborene spieler
in der mannschaft er ist der jüngste
das stimmt er ist tatsächlich das
nesthäkchen er ist das nesthäkchen der
mannschaft und macht uns sehr stolz
[Musik]
meine kinder haben in italien gesperrt
wir sind italiener und sie haben in der
pro patria gespielt in busto arsizio und
sehr gut aber das lugano projekt hat uns
sehr gut gefallen vor allem die tatsache
dass dieses jahr trainer wie viel das
sagen haben würde
die beiden
[Musik]
naja ding
gegen diese mannschaften tun sie sich
ein wenig schwer
im jahr es ist die erste erfahrung im
ausland für unsere jungs es war erst
letztes wochenende das ist verständlich
sie sind in der überzahl wir kommen
nicht richtig ins spiel
[Applaus]
das niveau ist sowieso hoch das niveau
ist hoch
scheint so wir müssen kämpfen mit mit
den starken nicht den schwachen
[Musik]
ihr kollege arthur jungen spieler haben
tapfer gekämpft beendeten das wiener
turnier aber auf dem elften platz von 12
[Musik]
also kinder das niveau dieses turniers
war ziemlich hoch
aber seid ihr glücklich
was hat er aus diesen spielen gelernt
dass man niemals aufgeben darf dass man
sich niemals ablenken lassen darf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sagen ihnen dass diese spiele dem
training dienen denn unser ziel ist das
champions league finale und das finale
der weltmeisterschaft wo wir mit euch
hingehen wir wollen dass unsere spieler
dieses niveau erreichen
[Musik]
[Applaus]